so tbs runs the baseball playoffs every
year and they asked us if we wanted to
do something baseball related and i said
i don't know
maybe give us the world series trophy
and they said yes they straight up gave
it to us for doing nothing
i can't wait to show it to my staff
they're gonna flip out
so beautiful
it is the prettiest
it's like the perfect size i don't want
it to be any bigger or smaller i mean
it's a piece of american history oh god
yeah i mean it's like
jimmy it sounds like you're just
agreeing and heightening whatever i say
is it a bird cage
it's a bird cage it's not a bird cage
it's shiny it's
it looks like half a piece of penny
you know what penny pasta it's a
baseball trophy
i think it's a bird cage get out
check it out nate it's the it's the
world series are you are you all right
it's bringing up some bad memories i got
bullied by these guys in high school oh
the baseball players weren't nice to you
no no no
trophy club
sorry drink they're so high and mighty
just because once a month they get to go
to the trophy museum
well look at me now trophy club i'm on
tv
i won i won
your school had a trophy club
to me it's special it is special it's a
special thing yeah it's a privilege
sorry who are you
do you work here no i'm steve garvey i
played for the dodgers and in 81 we won
this trophy bee you have one of these i
have one of those earned it didn't just
ask for it for your tv show you can
sleep with it i tried
shower with it
once
i'm gonna be honest with you steve i'd
like you to work here there's something
about you i'm gonna fire every writer
because they didn't appreciate this
piece of american history and i'd like
to hire you
and the trophy
deal
that sounds great pete
you're goddamn right
you